[Música]
el líder ruso alexéi navalni fue
trasladado a un hospital por encontrarse
en estado crítico de salud tras más de
dos semanas de huelga de hambre así lo
confirmó el servicio penitenciario
estatal de rusia entre la unión europea
manifestó su preocupación y eeuu amenazó
con consecuencias y el opositor pierde
la vida tenemos reportes de moscú
indias de puertos nuevos récord de
positivos por ccoo y 19 con más de
273.000 y mil 629 fallecidos en las
últimas 24 horas
el país vive uno de sus más datos picos
de contagios desde el inicio de la
pandemia para intentar contenerlo el
gobierno impuso seis días de
confinamiento en nueva delhi la capital
y pues el astronauta francés thomas
pesquet viajará hacia la estación
espacial internacional ubicada en la
órbita terrestre baja por eso durante
esta semana estas 24 les proponemos la
serie de reportajes de llamada thomas
pesquet viaje a las estrellas hoy en el
episodio 1 veremos la historia de la
estación internacional espacial
actualizamos la información de américa
latina y del mundo aquí en las 24
gracias por estar con nosotros mi nombre
es liliana valencia el servicio
penitenciario estatal ruso anunció la
decisión de trasladar a un hospital al
líder opositor a alexéi navalni
actualmente huelga de hambre y quien
representa un riesgo creciente de
insuficiencia renal y paro cardíaco el
gobierno de eeuu le dijo a rusia que
habrá consecuencias y navalny mueren los
seguidores de nava ni estaban convocando
protestas a nivel nacional para el
próximo miércoles la policía rusa ha
advertido a los manifestantes que no
acudan a dichas protestas los médicos de
naval y denuncian que no se les ha
permitido el ingreso a la prisión para
tratarlo desde moscú lousteau
corresponsal xavier colás nos cuenta los
detalles
navalny que lleva tres semanas en huelga
de hambre ha sido trasladado a un
hospital regional para convictos según
informa el departamento regional del
servicio penitenciario federal siempre
con el consentimiento del paciente se le
ha prescrito terapia vitamínica desde el
entorno del líder opositor dicen que su
vida pendía de un hilo y anuncian para
el miércoles la que se espera que sea
una de las protestas más grandes de la
historia moderna de rusia veremos el
poder de convocatoria mientras tanto la
justicia rusa prepara la ilegalización
del movimiento político de nava
y también de su fundación contra la
corrupción la llamada fbk de navalny y
sus oficinas de campaña están ahora en
el punto de mira de las autoridades
rusas desde la oposición temen que al
ser etiquetados como extremistas se
despeje así el camino para abrir cientos
de casos criminales contra estas
organizaciones y contra sus integrantes
en alemania el partido de los verdes
opositor a los conservadores de angela
merkel presentó a su candidata a la
cancillería de cara a las elecciones del
26 de septiembre se trata de anna lenna
barba con 40 años barba se postulará
como candidata de los ecologistas
partidos que aspira a ganar la
cancillería por primera vez esta
colectividad ha ganado ímpetu y en los
últimos años alcanzando un 20 por ciento
de la intención de voto sin embargo las
posibilidades para los ecologistas de
ganar la contienda electoral aún siguen
siendo pocas tras 16 años de gobierno de
los conservadores no es que este lunes
en mineápolis serán escuchados los
argumentos finales en el juicio al ex
agente de policía derecha bin acusado de
homicidio en el caso de la muerte de
georg floyd sobre él pesan cargos de
asesinato y de homicidio en primer y
segundo grado por lo que afronta una
pena potencial de 40 años de cárcel de
ambos las claves de este proceso que ha
captado la atención del mundo entero el
informe té rosa pérez
en mayo de 2020 eeuu estalló en
protestas anti racistas y contra la
brutalidad policial la muerte del afro
estadounidense 'george floyd a manos de
un policía blanco motivó a miles de
personas a salir a las calles a pedir
cambios reales
las manifestaciones se replicaron en el
mundo y llevaron a que estados y
ciudades estadounidenses aprobaran en
total 140 reformas de los cuerpos
policiales hoy entra en su fase final
el juicio contra derek shopping el ex
policía acusado del asesinato de floyd
mayweather sabrán que el 25 de mayo de
el señor derecho bin traicionó su placa
cuando usó una fuerza excesiva e
injustificada contra el cuerpo del señor
george floyd apoyando la rodilla contra
su cuello y su espalda hasta que el
último aliento de vida salió de su
cuerpo la defensa se basa en que la
actuación del ex agente se ajustó el
hermanamiento policial de sus 39 años de
carrera sin embargo el jefe del cuerpo
de mineápolis lo desmintió
y continuar aplicando tal nivel de
fuerza a una persona que estaba boca
abajo enmanillado y que no reacciona de
ninguna manera corresponde con nuestro
reglamento ni con nuestros valores por
otro lado los abogados de la ex policía
también alegan que floyd murió a causa
del consumo de drogas algo que el jefe
de la unidad forense del condado negó
mantengo lo que escribió en mi informe
del pasado julio fue un paro cardio
pulmonar durante el proceso el jurado
también escuchó a los testigos que
presenciaron los últimos instantes de
vida de floyd muchos de ellos todavía en
estado de conmoción mis padres hermanos
y amigos son negros podrían haber sido
de ellos he pasado muchas noches
pidiendo perdón a georges floyd por no
haber hecho nada más por salvar su vida
quien no aportó su versión fue el
expolicía que se acogió a su derecho a
no declarar
me acogeré al privilegio que me otorga
la quinta enmienda según cifras del new
york times' desde que empezó el juicio
contra el joven el 29 de marzo 64
personas es decir 3 por día han muerto
en encuentros con la policía la mayoría
de las víctimas fueron afro
estadounidenses y latinos residente
mexicano andrés manuel lópez obrador y
por lo que planea proponer las homólogo
estadounidense joe biden una estrategia
encaminada a organizar la migración
hacia la unión americana
la propuesta contempló programa de
empleo y apoyo agrícola destinado a
ciudadanos mexicanos y denominados
sembrando vida que podría crear hasta
1.3 millones de empleos en el sur de
méxico y las naciones centroamericanas
pensando en lo que voy a proponerle al
presidente baile vamos a tener una
cumbre sobre medio ambiente sobre el
cambio climático el jueves próximo y lo
que quiero proponer y lo comparto con
ustedes desde que se amplíe a
centroamérica el programa sembrando vida
sembremos árboles
índices supera los 15 millones de
contagios por ccoo y 19 mientras que a
la capital nueva delhi se dirige a un
confinamiento de 6 días debido al
aumento de casos tras registrar un nuevo
récord con 273.000 y mil 629 fallecidos
en las últimas 24 horas los hospitales
están colapsando sin camas ni oxígeno
disponible para sus pacientes y
distribuirse el primer ministro
británico boris johnson suspendió su
visita a la nación asiática que planeaba
para la próxima semana debido a la
situación actual de la pandemia
desde el lunes por la noche entra en
vigor el estricto confinamiento en nueva
delhi las autoridades de la capital
india afirman que la situación es
crítica ya que los hospitales se
enfrentan a la escasez de camas oxígeno
y algunos medicamentos el sistema
sanitario de nueva delhi es ahora
incapaz de aceptar un gran número de
pacientes si no tenemos un cierre ahora
puede haber una grave tragedia y no
queremos que nueva delhi se encuentre en
una situación en la que los pacientes
estén tirados en los pasillos de los
hospitales en la capital se han
registrado más de 25.000 contagios y 161
decesos en las últimas 24 horas
aproximadamente una de cada tres
personas sometidas a pruebas ha dado un
resultado positivo las autoridades
afirman que el 65% de los nuevos
pacientes de coronavirus son menores de
45 años y a menudo experimentan síntomas
más graves y a2 si es hoy día sentí como
si hubiera llegado mi hora es un
pensamiento son griegos tú eres lo que
pensabas en los últimos días han
aumentado las críticas contra las
autoridades por la gestión de la segunda
oleada de la pandemia con festivales
religiosos y mítines electorales a los
que asisten miles de
zonas en su mayoría jóvenes los médicos
creen que pueden ser más propensos a una
nueva variante del coronavirus
denominada de doble mutación descubierta
por primera vez en india en algunos
casos vemos pacientes jóvenes con lo que
se denomina enfermedad crítica por la
que necesitan grandes cantidades de
oxígeno o estar conectados a un
respirador en todo el país este lunes
las autoridades indias han reportado un
histórico récord de más de 273 mil
nuevos positivos y 1.619 fallecimientos
las peores cifras desde el inicio de la
pandemia esto eleva el número total de
contagios a más de 15 millones sólo por
detrás de eeuu
en noticias del continente africano al
menos un bombero ha resultado herido
mientras los servicios de emergencia
luchan para contener un incendio que
empezó el domingo en el parque nacional
table mountain a las afueras de la
ciudad de ciudad del cabo en sudáfrica
el incendio ya destruyó un restaurante
junto a las estatuas del colono
británico cecil roots
es una carrera contra el tiempo los
bomberos luchan contra un incendio en
las laderas del parque nacional de
hibble mountain en sudáfrica
el incendio se ha hecho con parte de la
universidad de ciudad del cabo
obligando a evacuar a cientos de
estudiantes las llamas han causado
estragos en la histórica biblioteca de
la universidad destruyendo libros
manuscritos y documentos de valor
incalculable como panfletos contra el
apartheid no obstante algunas de las
obras más importantes de la biblioteca
se han salvado gracias a la rápida
activación de puertas corredizas
en el campus hay más de 10 vehículos de
bomberos actualmente hay 3 edificios que
están ardiendo esporádicamente pero el
que es uno de nuestros mayores problemas
es la biblioteca en la que hay
muchísimos objetos de valor antiguos
otros edificios del campus también se
han incendiado mientras que este famoso
molino de viento que data de 1796 ha
quedado parcialmente destruido justo
fuera del campus en las inmediaciones de
table mountain el viento ha propagado
las llamas por el parque nacional a una
velocidad alarmante se ha instado a los
excursionistas a abandonar el lugar ya
los conductores a retirar sus vehículos
más de 150 bomberos están en primera
línea si cree que la causa del incendio
forestal que estalló el domingo por la
mañana es un fuego de los habitantes de
la calle desatendido las autoridades han
advertido que la lucha contra las llamas
podría durar días
y vamos a amarte porque el helicóptero
ingenuity de la nasa y su historia al
completar con éxito su primer vuelo
controlado en otro planeta
el equipo del laboratorio de propulsión
a chorro de la nasa encargado del
control de la misión desde su sede en
california confirmó que la nave había
logrado despegar mantenerse a flote
durante 40 segundos y aterrizar en el
cráter g0 del planeta rojo se confirmó
la recepción de una imagen en blanco y
negro tomada por el helicóptero así como
un vídeo grabado por el rover
perceptivas
el próximo jueves el astronauta francés
thomas que viajará hacia la estación
espacial internacional por esto durante
toda esa semana france24 les propone la
serie de reportajes llamada tomás pérez
que viaje a las estrellas para gravitar
alrededor del viaje la zona out hágalo
hoy en la primera episodio veremos la
historia de la estación espacial
internacional su interés científico y su
vertiente política en la creación
hoy está totalmente dedicada a la
investigación científica pero en el
momento de su creación la estación
espacial internacional también fue un
instrumento político la idea surgió en
1984 y al principio de los 90 el
proyecto estaba en punto muerto todo
cambió en diciembre de 1991 la unión
soviética colapsó y abandonó su programa
espacial muchos ingenieros especialistas
en misiles quedaron desempleados había
un cierto miedo por parte de rusia de
que se filtrarán sus habilidades sobre
todo teniendo en cuenta que en ese
momento estaba en una situación
económica muy difícil fue una fase un
poco complicada no sé si el objetivo era
recuperar a personal ganar habilidades
sí seguro gracias al talento ruso el
proyecto de la estación espacial
internacional resucitó en 1993 se firmó
un acuerdo de cooperación que la
convirtió en el escenario de unión de
los viejos enemigos el ensamblaje de
esta gigante maquinaria empezó el 20 de
noviembre de 1998 a 400 kilómetros de
altura se amarraron 15 módulos con una
capacidad de 900 metros cúbicos 400 de
ellos inhabitables
junto con 2.500 metros cuadrados de
paneles solares un laboratorio de más de
400 toneladas
de un campo de fútbol que se convirtió
en el mayor objeto artificial en órbita
la estación vuela 27 mil 600 kilómetros
hora por encima de nuestras cabezas y
una velocidad que evita que caiga sobre
la tierra y que permita a los
astronautas desafiar la gravedad cada
agencia posee una parte de la estación
en función de su aporte en el marco de
un estricto sistema de intercambio
huincul somos copropietarios así que hay
que saber compartir los gastos de la
estación hacemos lo que llamamos partes
es decir efectivamente trueques
desarrollamos material o capacidades de
abastecimiento y pagamos así de algún
modo nuestro alquiler por esta vía nos
tuvieron así durante varios años europa
ha pagado su alquiler el desarrollo de
un vehículo para fletar cargas y la
financiación de la cúpula de observación
cupola permitió obtener transportes
gratuitos de la nasa hace más de 20 años
que la estación está ocupada de forma
permanente y así está previsto que
continúe al menos por una década su
utilización acaba de ser prolongada
hasta 2030
así finalizamos central 24 pero los
invitamos también a que visiten nuestra
página web www punto frente a 24 punto
com para ampliar la información del
acontecer internacional en cuatro
idiomas nos vemos más adelante con más
información
[Música]
bienvenidos a